dos días después del inicio de la
primavera en el hemisferio norte Se
declaró el primer gran incendio forestal
del año en España las hectáreas
calcinadas desde el jueves de las
provincias de Castellón y teruel al este
del país aumentan a 3.000 pero el fuego
no está controlado y esta cifra sube con
el paso de las horas las llamas han
obligado a evacuar a unas de 1500
personas de 10 poblaciones y las
condiciones climatológicas hacen que las
labores de extinción se compliquen con
ráfagas de viento que podrían superar
incluso los 50 kilómetros por hora esta
tarde un viento que llega del oeste y
que reseca el ambiente Porque si por lo
menos llegara del este traería algo de
humedad del mar Mediterráneo además ha
llovido la mitad de lo habitual en los
últimos seis meses en la zona y las
temperaturas podrían alcanzar los 30
grados empeora esta situación que tras
las Nevadas del Invierno había muchos
árboles y ramas Caídas que no se habían
limpiado Y entonces se abre así de nuevo
el debate en el país sobre la gestión
que se hace de los bosques porque los
ingenieros forestales insisten en que la
prevención de incendios se debe hacer
durante los meses de menos calor para
evitar que este material se convierta
así en El combustible perfecto según los
datos del Ministerio de transición
ecológica español hasta el 28 de febrero
habían ardido 5.400 hectáreas muy por
debajo de las casi 10.000 hectáreas que
ardieron hasta esa fecha en 2022 año
fatídico en el que recordemos se
calcinaron 310.000 hectáreas en España
que fueron el 40% de toda la superficie
quemada en la Unión Europea